So yeah, every aetional document starts with html. <<
Okay. << Browsers are very forgiving. They will often just
like try to make something work, even if you don't
have the appropriate structure. But, it's best to follow it
[CROSSTALK]. So then you've got your heading. << Header, heading,
okay. << Yeah, so this is stuff that's not really,
necessarily displayed on the page. So you've got the title,
you've got some some sort of like loading of attributes.
>> Okay, so wait.
This linking style/main. That's where it gets
the CSS that we were modifying earlier?
>> Yeah. This stuff seems to be about like mobile.
>> Okay.
>> Stuff, so it's not super relevant to figuring
out how things work. At least on the web
page. And then we've got the beginning of the
body, which is really like what's shown on the page.
>> Okay, and so, I mean this is, every time I look at
html, I just see this wave of, you know, like indent and less.
More indented and less indented. How, how are you,
what do you thinking about when you're seeing this?
>> Yeah. So basically I want to look for two
things that are at the same indentation level. And that
tells me that, that's, so this is the beginning of
the block, and this is the end of the block.
>> Okay.
>> You also get this little closing guy, to say, you
know, I opened this div and now I closed this div.
>> You know, what is a div, why is it called a div, like...
>> I actually don't know why it's called a div, but.
>> Right.
>> Divs are sort of the basic building block
of websites. They're, they're just sort of
a thing. A a container for stuff. [LAUGH]
they're, they're sort of special kinds of things, like A is usually a, a link.
>> Okay
>> You've got forms.
>> What about, so, can you go back up a bit.
>> Mm-hm.
>> I mean, they all have this thing, this class.
Class container, class heading. So is that class just for
the, so when I'm writing the CSS file, and I want to
say everything that's a container is blue. Is that what it's for?
>> Pretty much, yeah. the, the JavaScript can also use these classes.
>> Okay.
>> It's, it's basically just a shorthand for saying
like, these are, these are similar things they should have,
they should look the same. You could have more specific
rules for like just a single one with an ID.
>> Mm-hm. But mostly yeah, it's for, it's for
the CSS. You could just have all of the styles in line, but that's...
>> That's messy.
>> Yes.
>> So that would be like, every time I had
a, what I wanted to be container, I'd have to say.
>> You'd have to have all. Yeah.
>> Okay. Yeah. I don't want to do
that. Okay so, paper divs. What are these H1's?
>> That's a header.
>> Okay P, what's P?
>> Paragraph.
>> Okay
>> I just sort of mixed the spacing around it. Standardized.
>> But it seems
like the Div is the more, like the really structural thing, and
this is the P's and the A's are just sort of like...
>> Things that go inside Divs usually, yeah. So, so Divs
can just be like a blob of text. They can be
a container that holds a bunch of different blobs of text.
It's really, sort of like the basic building block of HTML.
>> Okay.
>> Right.
>> Let me play around a bit and see if I can, you know, make some changes.
>> All right.
>> Thanks.